>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, THIS
MORNING PRESIDENT TRUMP
WEIGHED IN ON THE DACA
DEBATE HE TWEETED QUOTE
NEGOTIATIONS ON DACA HAVE
BEGUN.
REPUBLICANS WANT TO MAKE AND
DEAL AND DEMOCRATS SAY THEY
WANT TO MAKE A DEAL.
WOULDN'T IT BE GREAT FINALLY
AFTER SO MANY YEARS TO SOLVE
THE DACA PUZZLE.
THIS WILL BE OUR LAST
CHANCE, THERE WILL NEVER BE
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY
MARCH 5TH.
DAN BONGINO, IMMIGRATION
ATTORNEY FRANCISCO
HERNANDEZ.
ON THIS SHOW YOU HAVE SAID
SET AT THAT TABLE WOULDN'T
YOU TAKE THAT DEAL.
>> ME?
YES.
TAKE ANY DEAL THAT YOU CAN
ABSOLUTELY.
JUST PUT IT ON -- BECAUSE
THE HOUSE IS GOING TO RUIN
IT THE HOUSE IS GOING TO
DEPART FROM DONALD TRUMP AS
QUICK AS YOU CAN.
MOORE TOLD ME THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE TO COME TO THE TABLE.
BUT THE REPUBLICANS WILL
RUN.
>> Sean: I DON'T THINK SO.
>> THEY ARE SCARED AND THEY
WILL ABANDON A VOTER BASE.
MY FATHER HAS VOTED
REPUBLICAN SINCE THE DAY HE
BECAME A CITIZEN.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
HE SAYS, GUYS, WE ARE
LEAVING THEM ON THE TABLE.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
I DON'T THINK THE DEMOCRATS
WANT A DEAL DAN BONGINO.
>> THEY DON'T.
>> Sean: RATHER RUN ON THIS
IN 102018.
>> THEY DON'T.
>> Sean: SO, DAN?
>> NO, THEY ABSOLUTELY DON'T
WANT A DEAL BUT FRANCISCO IS
NOT TELLING YOU IS THAT
BARACK OBAMA HAD AN
OPERATIONAL FILIBUSTER PROOF
MAJORITY FOR MONTHS DURING
THE EARLY DAYS OF HIS
CAMPAIGN.
THE DEMOCRATS COULD HAVE
DONE IT WITH NO REPUBLICAN
HELP AT ALL, FRANCISCO.
AND DO YOU KNOW WHAT THEY
DID?
>> I GOT IT I AGREE WITH
YOU.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
>> HOLD ON, I'M NOT DONE.
THEY DID NOTHING.
PLEASE, LISTEN, THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF REPUBLICANS, ME
INCLUDED THAT DON'T BELIEVE
IN AMNESTY.
I DON'T BELIEVE IN BREAKING
THE LAW AND REWARDING IT.
FRANCISCO, HOLD ON, WHO
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT A DACA
DEAL.
I'M NOT ONE OF THEM.
>> MR. HANNITY, YOU AND I
HAVE GONE 17 YEARS.
THIS IS THE PERFECT STORM.
WE EITHER CUT A DEAL OR WE
DON'T.
THIS IS THE TIME TO DO IT.
>> Sean: I'M WITH DAN
BONGINO, I WOULDN'T SUPPORT
IT?
>> BUILD THE WALL.
WHO CARES?
GIVE HIM WHAT HE WANTS.
>> Sean: THIS IS THE PROBLEM
DAN BONGINO, YOU ALWAYS GET
THE SPENDING INCREASES --
I'M SORRY YOU NEVER GET THE
SPENDING DECREASES YOU GET
THE TAX INCREASES.
YOU NEVER GET THE WALL
BUILT.
YOU GET THE AMNESTY, TRACE
IT BACK TO 1986, 2006.
>> BUILD THE WALL.
>> Sean: IF THE PRESIDENT
DOES ANY DEAL HE BETTER GET
THE MONEY UP FRONT BECAUSE
THEY WILL NEVER FUND THE
WALL.
>> WHAT HAPPENED TO MEXICO
PAYING FOR IT BUILD THE
WALL.
WE HAVE TO LEGALIZE 100,000
MEXICANS TO BUILD IT AND
THAT'S A DARN GOOD START.
>> WE ALREADY SAW, THIS
SEAN.
>> I'M MEXICAN.
CAN I SAY THAT IT'S OKAY.
>> Sean: DAN?
>> WE ALREADY SAW THIS IN
THE REAGAN YEARS PROMISED A
BUNCH OF STUFF NEXT CHANGE
FOR AMNESTY AND YOU NEVER
ACTUALLY GET THE BORDER
SECURITY IN THE FUTURE.
HERE'S WHAT IS FAST
HERE'S WHAT IS FASCINATING.
FRANCISCO WHAT'S AMAZING SO
AMAZING HOW QUICK YOU ARE
WILLING TO THROW THE
REPUBLICAN UNDER THE BUS
HERE PRESIDENT ON OWN
TWITTER ACCOUNT OFFERING THE
DEAL.
DEMOCRATS WALKING AWAY FROM.
THIS WHOSE FAULT IS THIS.
>> I DIDN'T THROW THE
DEMOCRATS UNDER THE BUS.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO LET ME
FINISH A QUESTION HERE?
ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT THIS
RATIONALLY OR EMOTIONALLY IN
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES HAS OFFERED YOU A
DEAL.
JUST TAKE THE DEAL,
DEMOCRATS.
TAKE THE DEAL.
>> TAKE THE DEAL.
EXCEPT THE REPUBLICAN HOUSE
WILL RUN FROM IT.
THAT'S WHAT YOU GET.
DEMOCRATS ARE IDIOTS AND
REPUBLICANS WILL RUN FROM IT
PASS IT IN THE SENATE.
PUT IT ON THE TABLE AND
LET'S GO.
MR. HANNITY, YOU AND I HAVE